right it is 6 34 it is Tuesday it is tax
day
so what that means is if you haven't
already filed you still have you know a
few hours to get it in or you really you
have to file an extension what do you do
if you have some last minute questions
you need some last minute help Lauren
O'Grady is live at a local tax office to
answer some lingering questions Lauren
good morning to you
good morning yes today is the day you
got till midnight tonight to get those
filing in so here I am with Janelle King
here with Jackson Hewitt now let's talk
quick tips here if people haven't filed
yet what do they do you definitely want
to make sure against your nearest office
as you said we are open late for all of
our clients so you definitely want to
get in soon bring all your documentation
don't forget the social security numbers
and IDs and keep everything as organized
as possible so it makes the process very
seamless and pain-free
and then again and if you are going
through the paper route up until
midnight postage in the mail there now
extension let's talk if people know
they're not going to get it in how do
you file an extension absolutely we can
help you with that that extension
although it does not have you avoid any
kind of penalties or fees owed it does
give you peace of mind if you do need to
get some little extra time with getting
documents or even just need some extra
time to file so an extension can
definitely help you with that but just
keep in mind that if you do need to do
that it does not it can also delay your
refund if possible if you are getting
one as well thank you so much and again
there are some also free options on the
irs.gov website and then if you are
going through the route of extensions
like she said it doesn't avoid penalties
but it gives you the benefit of time and
avoid scams the IRS will never call you
or email you it's all through mail so
again just keep it on the whole tax
trade tax day today for now in North Las
Vegas Lauren negretti 8 news now all
right Lauren thank you very much uh no
procrastinate anymore you really can't
no they what do they say death and taxes
it's a guarantee yeah